yeah this is where baby samir he's three
months old was admitted
just a couple days ago here at the er
after his grandmother says he hasn't
been able to keep down his formula just
this past week several baby formula
brands recalled including simelac
aluminum and elacare formulas and the
food and drug administration received
four consumer complaints of bacterial
infections related to the formulas with
one death reported baby samir has been
experiencing weight loss as well as
fevers and utis and it wasn't until this
past week his family shares they
discovered the reason why
his mom and dad they've been so
concerned since day one of course this
is their first child
they are young parents and a lot of
times the doctors and nurses and
everyone even at me and myself at times
would just say you know this is normal
or they go through this and you know
we're just really not knowing his mom
and dad they pushed
this recall comes during a major baby
food shortage and it's unclear as of now
how many units the recall affected but
similac baby formula is extremely
popular within the u.s zamir is now
recovering at home and we plan on
speaking to his parents coming up in the
11 p.m hour that's going to be later
tonight reporting live madison kimbrough
live local now